>> Ben: IT TURNS OUT WORKING FOR
AMAZON IS HIGHLY DANGEROUS JOB
MUCH MORE THAN WORKING FOR BIG
BOX COMPETITORS ACCORDING TO
REPORT THERE ARE OVER 327,000
RECORDED INJURIES TO AMAZON
EMPLOYEES IN 2020 ALONE.
FOR EVERY 100 EMPLOYEE ESSEX
INJURIES.
NOW CURRENT AND FORMER AMAZON
EMPLOYEES ARE SPEAKING UP
INCLUDING GABE WHO SAYS WORKING
FOR AMAZON ALIENATING EXPERIENCE
AND EMPLOYEES ARE TREATED LIKE
ROBOTS.
WRITER AT THE FEDERALIST ALONG
WITH CONGRESSMAN RO KHANNA WHOSE
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT INCLUDES
SILICON VALLEY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> GABE, I WANT TO START WITH
YOU.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WAS ALIENATING ABOUT WORKING FOR
AMAZON.
>> I WAS AN VIETNAM PRIME
SHOPPER AS THE WHOLE FOODS
GROCERY STORE.
YOU KNOW, I ESSENTIALLY SHOWED
UP TO ORIENTATION EXPECTING AT
LEAST SOME DEGREE OF MAYBE A
SUPERVISOR OR SOMEONE TO REALLY
WALK ME THROUGH SORT OF A VERY
BASIC POSITION WHICH ENTAILS
PACKING GROCERIES THAT DELIVERY
DRIVERS WOULD EVENTUALLY PICK UP
AND ESSENTIALLY I GOT TO
ORIENTATION AND I WAS -- THERE
WAS REALLY NO ONE TO WALK ME
THROUGH THE EXPERIENCE.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS SORT OF THE
ENTIRE JOB THROUGH A WORK PHONE.
AND IT WAS REALLY A GLIMPSE INTO
THE JOB AS THERE WAS REALLY NO
ONE TO WALK US THROUGH HOW WE
WOULD DO THE POSITION.
>> Ben: CONGRESSMAN RO KHANNA,
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK WE
TALK ABOUT A LOT WHEN IT COMES
TO AMAZON ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
POLITICAL AISLE IS ITS POWER IN
TERMS OF MARKET IMPACT.
DURING THE PANDEMIC THOUGH WE
ALSO SEEN IT BECOME ONE OF THE
PLACES THAT REALLY THRIVED AND
SO ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
HAVE FOR YOU IS AREN'T THERE
OTHER NEGATIVE OUTCOMES THAT WE
HAVE GOING ON TODAY WITH A LOT
OF THESE ENTITIES THAT ARE
FRANKLY, DESPITE THEIR
PROPAGANDA, PUSHING OUT SMALL
BUSINESSES, PREVENTING THEM FROM
BEING ABLE TO HAVE SUCCESS AND
THE LIKE?
>> WELL, I THINK WE ARE SEEING A
GREAT DIVERGENCE.
I MEAN, YOU HAVE IN MY DISTRICT
A MARKET TAP OF $10 TRILLION.
A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES, A LOT
OF COMMUNITIES AREN'T
PARTICIPATING IN MODERN WELL
GENERATION.
I THOUGHT GABE BROUGHT A VERY
INSPIRING PIECE WHERE WORKERS
HAVE BASICALLY BECOME
ACCESSORIES TO ROBOTS.
I'M ALL FOR TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES GOING TO LEAD TO
PRODUCTIVITY WHERE IT'S GOING TO
HELP BENEFIT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BUT WE SHOULD NOT USE TECHNOLOGY
AS A TOOL TO GRAB POWER AWAY
FROM WORKERS TO MANAGEMENT AND
DEHUMANIZE THE WORKPLACE.
AND WE NEED REGULATION THAT
WOULD PREVENT COMPANIES FROM
DOING THIS.
>> Ben: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK YOU EXPERIENCED GABE WAS
BASICALLY JUST THE ATOMIZATION
AFFECT OF WORKING AT AMAZON IT
OFTEN ESCAPES THE DEBATE, THERE
ARE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THAT IN TERMS OF JUST AN ABILITY
TO RELATE TO EACH OTHER AS HUMAN
BEINGS WITHIN A WORKPLACE,
AREN'T THERE?
>> YEAH.
BEN.
I THINK PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THEY
LIKE TO BE WITH ONE ANOTHER.
I THINK THE WORKPLACE THERE IS
NO SECRET THAT A JOB, THE POINT
OF A JOB IS CERTAINLY TO GET
PAID.
BUT I THINK THERE ARE OTHER
ASPECTS OF A JOB SUCH AS
BUILDING A COMMUNITY WITHIN AN
AREA AND REALLY BUILDING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH YOUR
SUPERVISOR, YOUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUES.
AND CERTAINLY PLACES, YOU KNOW,
WITH THIS BIG BUSINESS THAT COME
INTO THESE COMMUNITIES AND THEY
SORT OF JUST BREAK UP AND DON'T
ALLOW PEOPLE IN AREAS TO REALLY
BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, IN THOSE
AREAS.
>> Ben: CONGRESSMAN, QUICKLY, I
FEEL LIKE ONE OF THE OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
APPRECIATE IS THAT THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE ONE EASY ANSWER ON
THIS.
PEOPLE WANT THE CONVENIENCE OF
AMAZON.
THEY WANT THE ABILITY TO HAVE
THINGS SHOW UP WITHIN A DAY OR
TWO.
AT THE SAME TIME, THERE CAN BE
SOME NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES THAT
COME WITH IT BUT I FEEL LIKE WE
DON'T REALLY WEIGH IN OUR
COUNTRY TODAY.
>> I THINK YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED NUANCED
POLICIES.
IT'S GREAT THAT THERE ARE RURAL
COMMUNITIES, UNDER SERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT NOW CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO PRODUCTS THAT THEY MAY
NEVER HAVE HAD.
SO WE DON'T WANT TO WHOLESALE
REJECT THE INNOVATION ECONOMY.
AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS OVER FACE TIME OR
SKYPE IS CREATING NEW
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WORKERS AREN'T EXPLOITED, ARE
THAT WORKERS STILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ORGANIZE AND THE
CONGRESS HAS BEEN ASLEEP, REALLY
WE NEED BIPARTISAN SMART
INNOVATION THAT DOESN'T HURT
INNOVATION.
GABE'S PIECE MAKES A WAY O